good afternoon strangely so to start
with I want to get you to do something I
want you to imagine a text string of a
billion uppercase G's right so it's just
GGG extending as far as the eye can see
now the reason I want to bring this up
is that there's a little bit of a
paradox about this so that's quite a
large piece of data if it was one byte a
character I guess we're talking about a
petabyte something like that but I was
able to describe it to you in under ten
words probably about three seconds so
there's something odd about this it's a
massive piece of data but I was able to
explain it to you as an audience in a
way that you could understand and so
there's this dichotomy between the
brevity of description for something and
the size of the end result that's what I
want to talk about today so specifically
I want to talk about komagawa of
complexity which is the notion that the
inherent complexity of a given piece of
data is how long the shortest program
you can write to make it is so in the
case of the G's I could write a very
short expression to make that happen and
I'll I'll show you that in a bit there
are other strings that are random you
can't find a way to shorten them in fact
a definition of randomness under the
Kolmogorov complexity model is something
that can't be described any shorter than
just literally saying what it is so in
order to talk about this I'm going to
use closure and there's a couple of good
reasons for it
one is that closure has overtones so I'm
going to be able to bring my musical
examples to life so you can hear them
and understand what I mean the other
reason is macros so what let's do is
that they allow you to talk about
programs at two levels at the level of
the the result but also the level of the
program itself and that's very useful
because that's what Komarov complexity
is all about viewing a program both as a
description and there is a result so
this picture is drawing hands by MC
Escher which was used by focus in his
talk the macro nomicon which is a very
good reference for the macros but I'll
just give a brief introduction to the
general mechanics of
the technology I'm using so you've
probably seen this before so if I put a
function and arguments like that I can
evaluate them in my editor the key thing
that makes a list but Lisp is of course
the fact that the function comes first
not not too complicated but the other
thing that makes lisp lisp
is that you can fix that if you want or
you can change things so if I wanted to
use in fix notation because it's more
normal to me I could write a macro to do
so so it takes a FB a and B the
arguments and outputs in the order that
Lisp expects it so if I define that then
I have the power to write programs in
that other style so instead of having
the plus at the beginning I can put in
the middle so first of all what I've
done is to just evaluate the macro
itself so hopefully you can see down the
bottom it's now rearrange two plus four
five and then if I evaluate it
completely it comes to nine so what I've
done is I've written something that is
manipulating not the end result not
there not the the evaluated symbols but
the raw symbols themselves and so that
ability to write code that talks about
actual code is going to be really handy
where I'm talking about the difference
between descriptions and the results so
if we think about that string of G's I
don't want to actually evaluate it
because obviously if it is you know it
is a petabyte that's gonna be something
that crashes my repple but closure has
lazy sequences so I can just evaluate it
and then take the first number of items
so there it is there's that that string
and you can see that it's not random it
has a pattern to it a very trivial
pattern G is repeating and that's why I
can write this little bit of code here
that defines the string itself that's
enough code when I evaluate it to
generate that whole string so I can say
that it doesn't have very much inherent
complexity relative to the language I'm
using to express it so as a side note
the Carmel Grove complexity model talks
about expressing programs in some kind
of universal language that you can you
can measure the choice of which
universal language and what kind of
features it has it does present
differences in what your results is I'm
not really going to go into that right
now
but it is an interesting area of it so
if we just consider that I want to
figure out what the description length
of an expression is like how long it
takes to type it I can write a macro to
do that because a macro operates at the
level of the program not the level of
the result so this did this macro
description length takes an expression
it gets the raw expression just the
symbols it converts it into a string and
then it just counts how many characters
there are so it gives it a score of how
long is that expression there's a very
nice symmetry between that and the
result length so what the result length
does is it's exactly the same but it's
not a macro so it's operating on the
evaluated argument so when I get the
expression it's it's evaluated to
whatever it should be and I do the same
process of converting it to a string and
then counting it so this is a unit test
here that shows that the description
length of this little expression is 13
so that's the string it's it's just a
bunch of g65 G's but in order to
describe it I only need 13 characters on
the flip side if I supply the same
expression in to result length I get 131
and that's because the result when I
print it out takes that many more
characters to represent so there is this
dichotomy between a concise description
and an expanded result
one of the reasons that is this is
interesting is it's a generalized idea
of compression so whenever you're
compressing any kind of file you're
doing this kind of thing so you might
not be deliberately thinking about
writing a structured program to output
the data but what the compression
algorithm is actually doing is
exploiting its understanding of what
kind of file there is so if you have a
PNG
it's exploiting the fact that it
understands that PNG are made out of
flat spaces of color if you've got a
text compression algorithm it's
exploiting its understanding that words
repeat and characters repeat so there's
a very close relationship between the
concept of expressing something
concisely and understanding it because
only if you can have a view of an
internal structure of a piece of data
can you express it concisely so you
could even say that the randomness of
something is the ratio between its
description length and its result length
so how much can you compress it
basically a compression ratio so if I
take that string of 65 G's you could say
that its randomness is you know about
10% now anything that you can't compress
it all uncompressible I guess you could
say is not random one slight
complication though is that working out
the most concise way to express a
particular value isn't decidable so of
this I have a truly marvelous proof that
this talk is too small to contain but if
you look it up on Wikipedia you'll find
it quite interesting so that's that's
the string of G's that that I wanted to
talk about but there's kind of another
kind so this is a box air on the g
string all right so it's also data
that's traditional musical notation but
you could view it as a sequence of
points on a graph right so as you read
the dots where they are vertically tells
you how high the note is where they are
horizontally tells you what the time is
there's a little bit obviously of extra
flourishes but for the point of my model
that will do so they're just a sequence
of points on a plane so I can model this
like I can model any other kind of data
in code and so I could for example
instead of outputting a billion
jeez I could at will output a
representation of a billion notes of G
and I could apply the same kind of
philosophy that I can work out how much
I understand the structure of it but how
briefly I can describe it
so here's a little bit of an example
just to show you what I mean so
hopefully you can see on the screen
there it's row row row your boat the
children's melody expressed as closure
data structures so hopefully it's broken
up in a way that's comprehensible to
humans and in the end what it results in
I'll just show you is kind of a bunch of
stuff that's a lot harder to understand
it's just a big pile of result it's
actually ok that that's hard to
understand because that makes the point
that by describing it in a brief way
I've actually exploited its structure
and being able to represent the meaning
of the music so for example there's a
bit in the merrily merrily merrily bit
where it's actually repeats a note of a
third length 12 times I could have
written that out by hand but because I
understand that that whole section has
these small notes I can describe it in a
more brief way which also shows my
understanding what's more row row row
your boat is something called a cannon
so a cannon is a special piece of music
that serves as its own accompaniment so
you play it once you functionally
transform it and then you overlay the
second time so I won't rely on your
having to visualize or aural eyes that
I'll play that to you now so what you
should hear is row row row your boat and
you should hear the two distinct times
of the melody happens
and because I understand that structure
it's not just a random collection of
notes I have this single line here
called cannon which describes that
duplication process so I've been able to
write it much more briefly because of
that and so if I look at the the
description length of row row row your
boat
it is 275 but if I were to write out the
notes by hand in that JSON format I
described it would actually 2081
characters so we're talking in about 10%
again I've managed to understand the
structure of that piece of music a nice
thing of once you start displaying your
understanding is you start being able to
make changes to it in a way that makes
sense to the data so the tempo of those
notes is controlled by a single piece of
code I've managed to concentrate my
understanding of the fact that a beat
takes a certain length of time so if I
want to for example make it a much
faster tempo I only need to change it in
one place and that's kind of a sign of
equality of my understanding because you
don't have to just think about Co magrav
complexity in terms of the description
to return the result you could also
think of it in terms of transitions
between different kinds of data so
there's something called conditional
coma graph complexity where you start
with a piece of data you do something to
it and you produce the end result so
that kind of tells you how much you have
to move to get from what you had to what
you want so in the case of playing this
much faster I just had to change one
character
I'm just changing in one place and that
shows that makeovers an understanding of
it now just because this is strange loop
so everyone wants everything to have a
theoretical basis this is a paper by
David Meredith which I really enjoy so
he's using karma grove complexity to
help him in his work as a musicologist
so the big well one of the big insights
in this paper for me which is called
analysis by compression is that you can
compare two ways of describing the same
piece of music based on how long the
descriptions are so if we say that a
description exploits the structure of a
piece of music then the shortest
description is the one that that
exploits the structure the most so it
understands that the best so there's
been quite a tradition in musicology of
and now analyzing music in certain ways
like explaining certain structures and
patterns and the notes but this using a
program to output the music and
comparing the length of it actually
gives you a quantitative way of
comparing two different ways of
understanding the music the other
insight which I actually maybe think is
even more interesting is that Meredith
talks about the process of listening to
music as a process of model formation so
you could see a song as a process of
explaining itself you know songs have
introductions they develop things get
broken down and put back together so
when you look at a piece of music or
when you experience a piece of music you
don't hear the whole thing at once right
what you hear is you hear incrementally
over time it's kind of a streaming model
formation process so your understanding
of it increases over time you might hear
a certain beat to start with that gives
you a clue about how fast it is then you
might get a certain baseline which tells
you what key it is and then you
gradually develop it so what he talks
about is the psychological effect of
music on you is one of the model
formation is the way he talks about it
and you can also see that as a special
case of conditional come graph
complexity so given I've heard this much
of the song how much kind of fitting of
the concept into my head do I need to do
to make sense of the next excellent
section and you kind of know that songs
are quite careful about how they do this
so not all genres of music introduced
new ideas at the same rate but they all
have to take that into account so some
genres may be you know free jazz might
be very quick and how how much invents
new concepts and how much how quickly it
wants you to revise your model of what
the song is in your head other genres
may be you know dance music that are
designed to be enjoyed while you know
while dancing away at a club they have a
slower rate of change now that's not to
imply there's a hierarchy in terms of
rates of change certainly not because
then I guess white noise would be the
ultimate musical expression but it's
just a way of understanding it and it
gives you kind of a real basis for
getting to grips with this so you know
my feeling is that I'm a programmer I
write code for a living so if I can use
the way that code works to help me
understand something else it really
gives me kind of leverage and and helps
me find new insight and joy I want to
show something else as well like as just
an example something called clapping
music because if the process of modal
formation which is really in a way you
stating musical ideas in your own
Universal comma graph language then how
well you're able to incorporate the
ideas into you depends on how well the
concepts in the music fit your mental
language you know if you've chosen a
language to compress data that
understands the concepts of the data
really well then you'll be able to
compress it really well if it doesn't
understand those concepts then it's
going to have a harder time so clapping
music which you can see as a paragraph
here excuse me is a piece by Steve Reich
a minimalist piece
so hopefully the code explains how this
structure works but I'm going to read it
for you as well so there's something
called an African Bell pattern which is
a traditional rhythm used in a lot of
sub-saharan African music what clapping
music is is you take the Bell pattern
and you loop it forever to start with
and you make that one part then what you
also do is use the concept of the cannon
so you accompany the first part with the
transformation of itself but this time
it's a little bit more complicated than
row row row your boat so rather than
just translate it in time and play it
later it keeps falling further and
further
behind so the first time it's in unison
but then it slips after eight bars falls
further behind falls further behind so
I'll play you what I mean
right so it's in you listen now it's
gonna slip out of time
all right secondly one of the clips is
now out of time so it's the same rhythm
but it's delayed so this piece consists
of basically the simple concept of this
one rhythm and two things just falling
further and further out of time so it's
actually a really good candidate for
describing things in musical notation
because sorry not music my vision unless
because I can describe these things as a
process I have one pattern and then I
repeat it it's actually quite a brief
thing but in musical notation I don't
have that same expressive power in music
notation that's just like you know
barks notes I'd have to kind of write it
out literally I could maybe do repeats
but I can't really capture the spirit of
it and it gets more and more extreme
than more interesting structures there
in a piece of music you just don't want
musical notation to be burdened by
having all that expressive power it's
not designed for that but obviously less
peers I probably should also mention one
other thing that David Meredith's paper
does explore which is the way that he
uses his programming ability to decode
music is by looking for geometric
translation so you can probably just see
a little bit up in that corner there
he's rendered the notes as points and
he's looking for when the same series of
points occurs multiple times throughout
the piece which is actually quite a good
way of analyzing barks music whether
with the same theme will occur multiple
times sometimes it'll be translated so
it might be you know higher or lower or
extended or compressed but this kind of
analysis can help do that and
davidmeredith actually has an automated
process for doing that so he's he's
experimenting with actually taking a
piece of music as a graph and then and
then working from that to form the code
but what I'm going to be coercing on
today is the reverse process so the
process of creating music by creating
these structures and descriptions and
showing how it makes it really
a really expressive way to get to where
you want to go and just as an incidental
thing you know clapping music is quite
minimal the characters to describe it
are only 228 but if I were to write it
out longhand using the json notation it
would always be a hundred thousand
characters so that shows that it's
really not complex in the literal sense
now again I want to stress that this
isn't a hierarchal description so the
fact that it's a really beautiful idea
that can be expressed succinctly I think
is actually the beauty of it and
actually in a way this could be a method
for talking about minimalism more
formally it's a minimalist idea because
I can describe it really briefly there's
actually a nice kind of confluence to
that it's not just a coincidence it's
something about minimalism itself that
attempts to compress ideas to a really a
really small set so I want to change
tack a little bit because as I started
to explore this idea that I could show
my understanding of something by writing
a really nice short program to express
it I started thinking of kind of all the
tricky things you could do with this
so the library of Babel is a short story
by bajas and this library of Babel is a
fictional library or at least I imagined
it to be fictional and it consists of
rows upon rows of books most of those
books are nonsense it's just gibberish
of text every now and again there'll be
a book that the first half of it for
example is like the Bible and the second
half just goes back to the gibberish so
what this library is is basically a
library of all possible books so on the
shelves everywhere there's books every
variation upon text that can fit into
410 pages is present somewhere in the
library so of course it has to be quite
large but not infinite and the
interesting thing about that is that the
difficulty then turns towards looking up
the book that you want so of course you
know the library has everything it has
you know has tomorrow's newspapers in it
has the Bible that it has it has the
short story in which the library is
described present in it many times in
many different forms with all possible
different type typos so quite a lot
quite an interesting concept it's it's
again
the learns of the kind of the minimalism
that the Steve Reich showed that bajas
was able to come up with a really sick
synced description of a really expansive
thing but the reason reason I want to
mention it is that there's a really
strong paradox there which is that
simple things can actually be super sets
of complicated things right so there are
things inside that library that are far
more complex far more detailed than even
the short story that describes it so you
can create a description that expands
out into something very large and that
very large thing can contain things that
are much more complex so I found that
quite quite an interesting concept that
you could have a small description that
could describe things that are more
complicated than itself of course you
just have to know where to look so I'm
going to write the library of Babel
enclosure so I'm gonna start by writing
the clean star which you probably know
from your days wrangling reg X's so
basically what this does is it takes a
list of elements and the way that it
worked it comes up with its library is
it takes a lazy sequence of the list of
elements and then it appends to that
independently all the different
characters it has so it produces all
possible strings based on its input so
you could you could put the four
characters of DNA in here and if you did
you would generate at some point the DNA
of everyone in this room yeah you would
generate all the DNA codes that we were
shown on the first day of the museum you
would generate that string of a billion
G's would be in there as well as it
happens and so what I'm gonna supply to
it is basically ASCII codes so what I'm
doing is generating all possible you
know all possible ASCII strings and so
it's a bit boring to start with so the
first five are just like the blank
string and the string was just a space
in the string with an exclamation mark
etc and eventually it expands so the 364
640 fifth string is the string JB right
which might mean something to some of
you who coming to strange there
and of course this is not random
alright so unlike ball hazards library
this one isn't finite so it's actually
far more expansive than bought houses
when he he talks about there being a
limit of size of each book so you could
eventually enumerate all the strings up
to four hundred and ten pages and once
he got there you'd know you were done so
this will continue forever but if I just
take the first ten thousand you can see
that it's it's not very random at all
because I'm able to describe this
library this library of Babel using not
very many characters and of course it's
infinite so if you were to take the
compression ratio of it it would
actually be infinitely small of
everything because I've described the
infinite structure with a finite
description so the idea of having a
simple description that talks about a
very complex thing is quite I think a
cool idea so before I get further into
following that I just want to describe
something from from this novel that I
found quite interesting so Carl Sagan's
contact was originally an attempt to
write a film that founded and he turned
into a novel which eventually became a
film so I thought that it got there in
the end
but there's a lot of interesting things
to this novel especially about what
interpretation means and what people who
don't share our cultural context or any
frame of reference would find the same
and I guess a lot of it is maybe
connected with with some of the
universality of the the lambda calculus
things that phil was talking about
yesterday but one of the really nice
details of this book is about pi so pi
can be described right it can't be
described with an equation so it's
called transcendental because that means
it transcends algebra we have to define
a process for it so it's a little bit
tricky but you can define PI as an
infinite sequence so what Carl Sagan
posits in contact is that once we as a
civilization evaluate PI to far enough
along it will cease to appear random
right there won't just be you know 1 7 7
6 3 9 whatever kind of the static will
clear and they'll actually be a message
which we just got a really nice bit of
science fiction because it it talks
about the idea that there might be
someone who can communicate with us at
the level of manipulating the natural
laws of the universe itself so we don't
I think the other nice thing about it is
it is reasonably mathematically accurate
right we it's probably not true but we
don't know for sure
as it happens that much about pi we know
it's not rational so we know it doesn't
cycle ever but we suspect there could be
some weird stuff in there so that could
include a message we come across one day
as it happens most mathematicians think
that it is something like the Tower of
Babel so a lexicon so that eventually
it'll have all finite strings somewhere
in there so we can probably operate on
that basis but it hasn't been proven yet
which is obviously the important thing
in mathematics but I wanted to work out
a way of maybe using PI to make music
because it you know has all these random
digits maybe I could encode it but this
fact that I didn't knew that it didn't
necessarily contain all substrings kind
of thumb me out I thought that would be
an interesting aspect that the piece of
music I'm sorry switch to something
called the shampo noun word which does
have that property so the champion word
is basically just a serialization of all
the integers so fairly easy to define
wasn't defined actually in an
undergraduate thesis so if we take
actually let's take a bit more later if
we take the first you know one hundred
and sixteen characters of the champion
onward you can see that it starts by
just counting one two three four when it
gets to ten all it does is splits them
out so one zero one one one two so this
is also a transcendental number well it
is if you interpret it as a as a decimal
fraction and it does contain everything
in it right so any any string of numbers
that you want you can just wait till
that number comes along and gets
serialized so we know that it has all
the numbers you know we know it's a
lexicon so that's quite a cool property
to have um and one of the reasons why
it's a cool property is that we can
design a lexicon song
so if we dig hold this number in the
right way we know that we're going to
hit every other every other song
eventually right so one thing that it's
strangely that I don't know maybe
sometimes disappoints me is that people
just aren't practical enough so there's
all these talks about you know like
building lisps and stuff I mean there
was one that I shouldn't lie there was
definitely one very practical one about
you know revolutionizing the the
Knitting industry via by machine printed
dodgers but most of the talks kind of
were just about learning and stuff which
is you know obviously not great for us
who were you know programmers who are
really just thinking about return on
investment of our time so so I didn't
want to be one of one of them one of you
what I wanted to do was show that this
is actually something quite practical so
I've made this song that actually and
I'll show you the copyright infringement
song I call it for reasons that will
become obvious so what it does is it
skips to a particular part in this song
and you'll see why we need to skip to in
a minute and that decodes it into three
parts puts it in a particular tempo and
plays it so what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna play the song itself from
scratch to start off with and you'll see
what we need to skip to
this is probably not the most beautiful
three voices that are just don't carry
eventually these things will go through
pop all possible notes and come around
to all possible three-part songs but
absolutely it's a lexicon for songs but
it's kind of is charming in itself but
it's not particularly musical so the
point is that if we can skip to a
particular point you know we can find
the kind of the bits in it that are
really quite good right so what I've
chosen is I've chosen the song blurred
lines because it was embroiled in its
copyright controversy of its own and
before I go too far into that just as a
detour the kind of the haha only serious
misogyny in blurred lines has kind of
makes it a particularly good target for
something having gone wrong with it
legally and if you want an antidote to
me having sighted it I have a look in
the references for the talk and there's
a there's a really nice send up a book
called defined lines by the law of you
girls and New Zealand University so I
definitely don't take this as an
endorsement by mentioning it but what I
have here is I have the point in the
song where I found bird lions you might
know that blurred lines had its own its
problem with Marvin Gaye's estate so
there was a there was a an idea that had
actually copied a Marvin Gaye song and
I'm not sure I necessarily agree with
that too much but it doesn't have to be
subjective so if we were able to
represent both of them using this
musical notation we'd be able to get to
the point where we could actually you
know evaluate the conditional comma
graph complexity of the two so you'll be
able to say how different one song is
for another but I might just because
this is all about demonstrations I might
just skip to that part of the copyright
infringement song where blurred lines is
and the reason I have to skip is that I
don't think just waiting to get there
would be a good idea because there would
be well there'd be a couple of practical
reasons one one thing would go wrong
would be that we get kicked out of this
room another problem would be that the
Sun would expand and destroy the earth
and this would all happen long long long
before we got anywhere near where this
where this is so the skipper head is
definitely an important feature but
let's just listen to it
so exactly boy lands it's probably it's
probably close enough
but this is just part of an infinite
song that has nothing about blurred
lines anywhere in the song itself I just
skip to the point where this happens
I'm totally blameless life that each
time it goes around it won't exactly be
the same so it sounds tired to you like
it's a blue that's because we're just in
a bit where this thing occurs in very
similar ways over so there's a slightly
different mode of you
right and the reason why I wanted to
talk about practicality is well it's the
kind of the copyright issue right so on
one hand this song does I guess infringe
on the copyright of all previous music
which is I guess a problem from a legal
point of view because it has blurred
lines in it it does have mark and Marvin
Gaye's song in it so it has both of them
as it happened but they're really like
important bit is that every future piece
of music in fringes on its copyright so
so my bet is that on balance that will
leave me in in the black bubble we'll
see you back just will I get the chance
I want to give an honorable mention to
all checkers album auntie or EP because
they kind of had similar ideas about
messing about with complexity and
protests so in 1994 in the UK there was
a minority one not a minority govern the
government with a thin majority and
things weren't going up for it so well
in the polls so coincidentally there was
a moral panic that they needed to
address and in that this particular case
one of the aspects to it was raves you
know youth going off and like dancing
and stuff and this was obviously
something that need to be cracked down
on but the problem was that it's kind of
hard to define like what is a rave and
what isn't so the law actually quite
cleverly talked about it as a succession
of repetitive beat so this is I guess
how you could differentiate between
people raving and you know respectable
people just doing morris dancing or
whatever um so what what ortega did is
they created this album so two of these
tracks on this album come with like a
warning that they have repetitive beats
and so you shouldn't like played in a
field with your with your mates right
but the third song it doesn't so the
third song deliberately has no
repetitive beats every beat is unique so
it keeps on cycling so it's kind of it's
not exactly a formal lexicon and it does
come with a warning so it says that if
you are going to play this track flutter
which just has all these unique beats
you should make sure you have both a
lawyer and a musicologist present to
show that that you aren't actually in
infringement of the law
but I thought was a really charming
thing to do all right so I want to end
this by doing a bit of actual kind of
more playing and music this time
something that I've come up with just a
to round it off so we've talked about
the idea of a cannon which is a piece of
music that is accompanied by itself so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I'm gonna
make a cannon out of the letters G EB
I'm going to do it by following the
theme of this talk right so we said that
Karma grow of complexity is about the
dichotomy between the description and
the result so what I'm doing is I'm
interpreting the notes as GEB on the
scale you probably know them and also
via their ASCII codes with a bit of type
punning and just playing them as well so
I'll show you how that how that sounds I
just need to get rid of something first
so the reason I wanted to build up this
is I want to make the point about the
cycle
the davidmeredith talks about right so
you're gradually learning what this song
is about
that's all itself is an explanation of
what
so what we're doing now is just setting
the scene so I'm playing the the notes
GE and me both of ASCII codes and as the
little literal notes GE be a bit of a
base thing underneath
so I'm gonna gradually do is introduce
new elements and as this happens you're
gonna gradually understand more about
other Souls
so I'm gonna start by putting like a
briefing which is gonna enhance your
model because we're gonna move from just
having the base harmonies to something
that's playing around with those out
and you can notice that because I'm
expressing this code every time I make a
change I feel I'm kind of slightly
cheating by having to type some things
before but I'm just getting on my model
I'm just playing that moment over and
over
so the process of me creating this is
actually mirrored in the process of your
understanding
let's enhance it a bit more
maybe well
laughter one more time
I'd say the last iteration
next time around we can approve our mail
you can feel your understanding of what
it is development
what I'm using here is a little bit
similar to steam right
that's
like to you because you don't worry good
at listening
you're my cellie no good at listening to
that finally
what often happens in both of her talks
in
than everything else is that you want to
approach the thing from another angle I
need you to go to the play we understand
approach it from other angles so you
understand
the variation so we using different
chords using the same instruments we're
using the same template
but now you just
but is that - speaker bit aggressive
talks about things from a completely
different angle you've only got to live
in an amount of time to time actually
the main thing before before the unit
their interest
what I was and how these ideas together
we're back to the main game
they were
now a new understanding
let's just uh all the bins together
very to get the same thing that just
here from a slightly different
but I've only been able to play this
because I I graduated they do modern
formation
so I talked about is being a cannon
is another dimension I want to make some
only cannons have two iterations of the
same thing
I want to do is I wanna do it
and another another one kind of spinal
tap stone so we've talked about lis the
description we've talked about the
result so what I'm gonna talk about is
is what those letters mean as well
peddle right so good singing
text-to-speech sure this is in a way
another cannon right we've got another
layer of meaning and it's expressing the
same the same theme in three different
in three different stages
esra
of course my point is that the music
depends a lot on your context and that
includes your culture so I'm gonna have
some distortion to it which as Ray might
mean different things grandparents in
you but I
in my culture a tie either rocking out
esra
see that
let's bring a riff back
next one
let's take the top
peddle so I've just I just wash that
kind of the top of the time it's just
it's just playing a confluent
it's maybe lower to middle
I certainly didn't bring their luck
and bringing back
your eminence
pedal
esra
[ __ ]
it's a gradually funny way
gödel Escher Bach
and don't thanks